There's also that plume being in the air,
which restricted flying is all tied into the death of that journalist Michael
Hastings.
Do you know that?
Oh,
that crazy conspiracy theory.
It's one of the weirder ones,
man.
It's one of the weirder ones.
This guy,
Michael Hastings was this sort of renegade journalist type character and he went
to Iraq or Afghanistan,
um,
I wanna say Iraq,
but it might've been Afghanistan.
He went there with the troops and he got stuck there because of that volcano.
So because was stuck there,
everybody got comfortable with him being around and they started saying crazy
shit.
They start joking around about Obama or stuff like that and he put all this in
the article and when he put all this in the article,
the general had to resign and he was like one of the most popular at most
powerful generals in the army.
Then shortly thereafter,
homeboy decided to go 120 miles an hour down sunset slam into a tree and his car
exploding and everybody's like,
it's a fucking murder.
Hits assassination.
And then there was all these tech guys,
they were coming out and they were saying,
listen,
you abso lutely can hack a car and change the direction.
Change the the what?
What?
The car does take control of the car.
You absolutely can do that.
And they were like,
abs.
Absolutely.
He was like,
absolutely.
It absolutely 100% you do it.
Do you have,
we know these people,
there's videos of people falling asleep and their Teslas,
right?
The car just drives you there.
You get on the highway,
just drives you.
We know that's real.
It turns,
it'll turn,
it'll make turns for you.
It'll park.
They have cars that park.
You don't think that they can,
that they figured out a long time ago say,
wouldn't it be cool if we could just tap into that and make this motherfucker
drive into a tree on Star Hill?
Didn't they would be so incompetent that I don't want to hear any conspiracy
theories ever again because of the government didn't look at that stuff.
If the government like this s assens didn't look at that and go,
blah,
blah.
Hold on a second.
So you're telling me if the head of Isis is in a car and it's a Mercedes,
we can hack into that car and make that motherfucker drive off a cliff.
We can do that.
Okay,
well let's do that.
I'm fucking a hundred percent those people all day or trying to figure out way
to kill bad guys.
You don't think they would think of that?
Of course they would.
So that's the scary thought.
But then the other possibility is homeboy was losing his mind because of the
pressure,
which is entirely possible.
He always have to like look at everything.
You got to look at all sides.
You really do.
It's so,
it's so easy to just pick a side on any story or a conspiracy theory or eat
anything.
Even a political opinion.
So easy to just dig your heels in.
But in this one,
he got to look at this guy.
They definitely found amphetamines in his system.
They said,
and that's not uncommon for writers.
Writers love Adderall if fucking love it.
Apparently I have a friend who's a journalist,
says everybody who's a journalist is on Adderall.
Obviously he's exaggerating.
The one guy's out there like,
no folk,
not fucking mood,
but um,
who was it that was a doc?
Oh,
my friend Doctor Rati Mckee,
the,
the stem cell doctor from Vegas.
He was telling me about people that were taken Adderall,
like when he was in college.
And he's like,
Holy Shit,
it's my breath smell.
See throws me Listerine.
Press trips.
Okay,
dude,
I'll fucking take one.
Finally flipped it cry.